HE WILL CONNECT ON THE FIRST.
PAUL GEORGE IS ONE OF THE REAL
STARS OF THE NBA.
HE HAS HAD SOME BRILLIANT
PLAYOFF MOMENTS WITH INDIANA AND
OKC AND WITH THE CLIPPERS, BUT
HE HAS HAD HIS SHARE WITH THE
DISAPPOINTING PERFORMANCES.
HE HAS BEEN PLAYING HIS HEART
OUT IN THIS SERIES, AND SO MUCH
RESPONSIBILITY WITHOUT KAWHI
LEONARD.
THE CLIPPERS NEED HIM TO BE
AGGRESSIVE, BUT EFFICIENT, AS
YOU GUYS ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY HAVE SCORED TEN STRAIGHT,
BUT BEVERLEY IS LAUGHING AND
MOCKING THE CALL.
THE CROWD IS LETTING BEVERLEY
KNOW WHAT THEY THINK OF IT.
HE COULD CARELESS, BECAUSE HE
SAYS THE KEY THING FOR PHOENIX
IS IF CHRIS PAUL GOT HURT.
THEY ARE GOING TO REVIEW IT.
>> Referee: THE PLAY IS UNDER
REVIEW FOR A FLAGRANT FOUL.
>> Mark: IT IS A FOUL, BUT IT IS
NOT A FLAGRANT FOUL.
>> Mike: BEVERLEY IS TRYING TO
FIGHT OVER THE SCREEN, AND HE
DREW THE CONTACT, BUT IT IS NOT
DELIBERATE, BUT HE DID BRACE THE
FALL WITH THAT LEFT HAND.
BOTH OF THOSE GUYS ARE SO GOOD
AT THE THEATRICS.
>> Jeff: AND HE IS SAYING THAT
CHRIS PAUL FLOPPED OR WHATEVER.
>> Mike: IT IS A FOUL.
>> Mark: ONE THING THAT MAKES
PATRICK BEVERLEY A GREAT
DEFENDER AGAINST CHRIS PAUL OR
DEVIN BOOKER, AND IF YOU ARE
PAUL OR BOOKER, YOU KNOW THA